[موسيقى]
امام الاوضاع صحيه صعبه وموجات النزوح
المتواصله من الخرطوم باتجاه المدن
السودانيه الاكثر امنا لا يبدي طرفها
صراعيه يمرون تجاه وقت دائم للنار فكلو
الاتهامات مستمر وجميع المتحاربين يتحدثون
باسم الشعب وعذرهم في الحرب انهم يريدون
لهذا الشعب ان يعيش بحريه وسلام تغطيه
مستمره على شاشه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اعزائنا المشاهدين التغطيه المستمره كما
تتابعون في هذه اللقطات المباشره التي
تريدون من جده وعدد من الدبلوماسيين في
استقبال الرعايه الاجانب الذين وصلوا الى
جده قادمين من بناء بورتسودان بعد عمليات
اجلال تعد الاكبر من السودان بقياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهناك ايضا كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطات
الكثير من الدبلوماسيين
وقاده البعثات الدوليه الذين هم في
استعداد استقبال رعايه بلدانهم الذين
وصلوا على عده رحلات بحريه الى ميناء
جده وايضا الى مطار قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده والمتابعه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه لوصول المزيد من النازحين
واللاجئين الذين خرجوا من السودان هربا
بنا تون المعارك الدائره ما بين الجيش
السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه اذا التغطيه مستمره
كما نتابع في هذه اللقطات المباشره على
شاشه العربيه لوصول المزيد من الرعايه
الاجانب طبعا نتحدث هنا عن وصول سفينه
امانه وعلامتها
1687 شخصا من ثمان وخمسين جنسيه اذا من 58
جنسيه في عمليه تعد الاكبر لاجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان
اذا مانا وصلت تحت حمايه القوات البحريه
السعوديه وعلامتها
1687 شخصا من 58
جنسيه جنسيات اوروبيه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن اسيا وايضا من المملكه
والخليج على متن هذه السفينه السفينه
امانه التي وصلت تحت حمايه القوات البحريه
السعوديه الى المملكه في عمليه اجلاء هي
الاكبر حتى الان كما نتابع في هذه اللقطات
المباشره التي تشاهدونها الان حصريا على
شاشه العربيه اذا نحن بانتظار
نزول اولئك اللاجئين بعد الاستعداد
في الحقيقه التوصيف الاهم والاشخاص الذين
هربوا من الصراع الدائر وهو عمليه اجلاء
حقيقيه لرعايه الدول الاجنبيه فالاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم هو الوصف الدقيق لما
يجري حاليا على متن سفينه امانه تحت حمايه
القوات البحريه السعوديه
وتنسيق مع السلطات السودانيه لوصولها
الاشخاص بامان تمهيدا الى نقلهم بعد ذلك
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن جده
تحديدا الى
مدنهم وبلدانهم
سنكون معكم اذا في تغطيه مستمره لنزول
وتواصل عمليات الاجلاء من السودان وهذه هي
العمليه الاخيره التي وصلت الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه
وتحديدا السفينه مالا التي وصلت تحت حمايه
القوات البحريه السعوديه وعلامتها
1687 شخصا من ثمانيه وخمسين جنسيه
عدد من القناصل وعدد من الدبلوماسيين
الذين
هم في الميناء
لاستقبال رعايه بلدانهم تمهيدا لنقلهم الى
وجهاتهم النهائيه
اذا نتابع الصوره مع زميل سلطان السلمي
اذا سلطان تتابع لنا عمليه
اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب السودان ووصول
السفينه امانه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحري
بالفعل كما نشاهد الان انتهت القطع
البحريه الخاصه بالقوات البحريه السعوديه
بالايقاف هذه السفينه التجاريه التي تسمى
بامانه جده على متنها كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
شخص ممن تم اجلائهم من قبل الحكومه
السعوديه وتحديد من قبل قوات البحريه
السعوديه من ميناء بورت سودان وصولا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريني يتحدث على 58
جنسيه عربيه وامريكيه وكذلك اوروبيه فقط
13 السعوديه تواجد على متن هذه السفينه
ونؤكد ان الحكومه السعوديه تتعامل مع معظم
الطلبات بشكل كبير والتعامل مع الطلبات
التي تستقبلها السفر السعوديه في الخرطوم
ايضا نتحدث على وجود سته واربعين امريكي
يتواجدون على متن هذه السفينه اذا نتحدث
على وجود 239 يمني و13 السعودي وايضا
نتحدث على وجود 1998 السوداني من
دبلوماسيين وغيرهم واثنين
سوري ايضا العدد الاكبر هم لمواطنين
الاندونيسيين بعدد 500 وستين شخص اذا
نتحدث عن وجود 58 جنسيه كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل الان انتهت عمليه ايقاف وترسيه هذه
السفينه الضخمه بوجود عدد كبير من
القيادات الامنيه التابعه للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وايضا كذلك بوجود ممثلي بوجود
ممثلين الدبلوماسيين التابعين لهؤلاء
وممثلين هؤلاء الرعايه وايضا بوجود ممثليه
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وكما ذكرنا الان
سوف تبدا عمليات الانزال كما نشاهد الاغلب
وعدد كبير من يتواجدون على سطح هذه
السفينه بعد وصولهم بطبيعه الحال الى بر
الامان هنا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
كما نشاهد الان الكل يريد النزول بشكل
مبكر بعد معاناه كبيره عاشوها ولحظات صعبه
كانوا يعيشونها في الخرطوم وفي بورتسودان
وفي المناطق التي بها اشتباكات مسلحه بين
قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني وصلت هذه الرحله بعد ان
استمرت ثمانيه الساعات اثناء عمليه النقل
بين بورت سودان وبين قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه وسط حمايه من قبل القوات البحريه
السعوديه التي عملت على تامين هذه العمليه
النقل او عمليه الاجلاء بشكل كبير جدا
نشاهد الان امامكم في الكاميرا عدد من
الممثلين والسفراء والدبلوماسيين لهؤلاء
الرعايه لا
وانهاء كافه اجراءات سفرهم من قبل الحكومه
السعوديه ومن قبل ممثلينهم بشكل كبير جدا
خلال الفتره او خلال ساعه الى ساعتين سوف
يتم منها كافه اجراءات السفر التابعه
لهؤلاء الرعايه سوف تستمر عمليه الانزال
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل من ساعه ونصف الى
ساعتين ونصف سوف يتم انهاء الاجراءات
ونزولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ومن
ثم الى مقرات السكن سوف يتم استقبالهم
بالاعلام وبالورود وبالحلوى كما هو
المعتاد نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء استمرت
لمده ثلاثه ايام هذه هي السفينه او الموكب
الثالث والسفينه السادسه التي عملت على
نقل الرعايه من بورتسودان وسطه
قوات البحريه السعوديه ووزاره وبالتنسيق
مع وزاره الخارجيه والسفاره السعوديه في
الخرطوم وعدد كبير من القطاعات الحكوميه
التي صخرت كافه جهدها للتعامل مع الرعايه
او التعامل مع ملف الرعايه واستقبالهم
بشكل كبير وبعمليات اجلاء مستمره منذ
ثلاثه ايام وحتى هذه اللحظه من المتوقع
خلال الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحلات
اجلاء قادمه من بورد سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه سوف نستمر بتغطيه عمل
الملف والعمليات الاجلاء المستمره اللي من
قبل الحكومه السعوديه
للرعايه الدول الشقيقه والدول العربيه
والدول الاجنبيه طيب اذا كما نتابع في هذه
اللقطات المباشره والحصريه من
كاميرا العربيه والزميل سلطان السلمي من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه
السعوديه
بالدخول لمره الاولى وبلقطات حصريه وخاصه
لقناه العربيه
الان سوف يتم استقبالهم من قبل سكات
السعوديات والقوات والقوات الامنيه بمختلف
اشكالها بالحلوى
وبالورود كما نشاهد طيب سلطان نحن نحاول
فقط التاكد من وصول الصوره دائما بشكل
واضح لانه من الاحتمال بشكل كبير ان تنقطع
اللقطات من داخل السفينه ولكن فيما تبقى
لنا من لقطات ومن تغطيه هل هناك معلومات
عن هذه السفينه السفينه امانه او امانه هل
هناك من المعلومات عنها ما الجهه التي
قامت بتوفيرها من اجل نقل اولئك الرعايه
القادمين من بورسودان
بطبيعه الحال هي السفينه سعوديه تسمى
بامانه جده تم تفويلها من قبل الحكومه
السعوديه لنقل اكبر عدد ممكن من الرعايه
نظرا لكثره الطلبات التي استقبلتها
الحكومه السعوديه وتحديدا السفاره
السعوديه في الخرطوم من قبل دول مختلفه
على مثل هذه السفينه كما ذكرنا 58
جنسيه فلذلك السعوديه تعمل على عمليات
النقل عبر السفن البحريه الضخمه او فرقات
السعوديه وكذلك اليوم عبر ممكن نتعرف عليك
ممكن هذا اول شخص سوف يقوم الارض
سلطان كما اشرنا قبل قليل وجودك داخل
السفينه قد يحرمنا من هذه الصور بامكاننا
الخروج ربما من السفينه بشكل ما من اجل
التقاط المزيد من اللقطات المباشره قبل
قليل كنا نتابع مع زميل سلطان قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه وصول اول دفعه من ربما
الدفعه الاكبر تحديدا من رعايه الاجانب
الذين وصلوا الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده على متن السفينه امانه التي وفرتها
سلطات السعوديه من اجل اجلاء اكبر عدد
ممكن من الرعايه العرب والاجانب من
العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم كنا نتحدث عن رقم
1078 ربما راكب علامه هذه السفينه من ما
يقارب 58
جنسيه وصلوا الى ميناء القاعده قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في عمليه الاكبر عدد
كبير جدا كما نتحدث ونعود مره اخرى
لمتابعه هذه اللقطات المباشره من داخل
السفينه بعد عوده الارسال
عمليات نزول الركاب
مستمره نتابع مع زميل سلطان تفضل سلطان
مشاهد انزال احدى السيداتهم ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه وكبيرات السن يتم
انزالهم الان من قبل الموظفين العاملين
هنا في علامه السفينه امانه جده نتعرف
عليك
طيب هي اعتقد ان ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
الحمد لله على السلامه نقولكم تفضلوا
تفضلوا حياكم الله
طيب نتعرف عليك محمد مويه الزكي من
الجاليه العراقيه محمد ممكن تحاكينا كم
استغرقت الرحله ساعه وكيف تم اجلائكم
والله احنا تم جلانه بالباصات الى
بورسودان ومن بعدها يعني مكرمه المملكه
يعني بارك الله فيهم واخذنا بالعبارات
تقريبا الساعه سبعه الصباح غادرنا من
بورسودان والحين وصلنا المملكه الحمد لله
على سلامتكم بطبيعه الحال مشاهد ماسويه
عشتوها في في السودان اي كان موقعكم لو
ممكن توصف لنا ابرز الاحداث اللي عشتها
والله احنا كنا عايشين في منطقه يعني
الطائف والسحاب والمناطق الامر كان في
بدايه الاشتباكات لكن في بعدها بعدين
تطورت الاوضاع مشينا الى فندق المؤقتا الى
ان يتم اجلانه كانت اشتباكات عنيفه في بعض
المناطق لان الضلوبه عشوائي كان وجدتهم
انا شخصيا
والله يعني اخوك عراقي يعني الحمد لله
قدرنا ندبر امورنا لكن ماساه كانت بالنسبه
للعوائل بالاخص مع فقدان المي المي نضيف
للشرب والمواد الغذائيه شكرا لك شكرا شكرا
شكرا الان سوف ننتقل الى هذه المنطقه الى
اعلى السفينه
اذن لقطات المباشره نعود مره اخرى الى
تنويع ما بين اللقطات التي نستطيع الحصول
عليها من خارج السفينه امانه امانه التي
وفرت الحكومه السعوديه من اجل نقل اكبر
عدد ممكن من الرعايه الجانب ومنهم ايضا
سعوديون ومن جنسيات مختلفه وصلت الى 58
جنسيه ولا لقطات دائما متابعه ومباشره على
شاشه العربيه من داخل قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه زميل سلطان
انقل لنا المشهد لديك ما الذي يدور حتى
الان بانتظار عوده صوره بشكل كامل من داخل
السفينه الامانه
سلطان
طيب على العموم فقط نذكر ببعض المعلومات
التي نتابعها الان بشكل مباشر على شاشه
العربيه السفينه التي وفرتها الحكومه
السعوديه من اجل الاستجابه لطلبات الكثير
من الدول لصديقه وشقيقه فيما يتعلق
بالمساعده في اجلاء رعاياها من داخل
السودان خاصه من العاصمه الخرطوم التي
تشهد اشتباكات محتدمه لليوم الثاني عشر
على التوالي هذه السفينه التي وصلت قبل
قليل ورست بشكل كامل في البناء يبلغ عدد
ركابها ما يقارب
1687 شخص من ثمانيه وخمسين الجنسيه
الجنسيه الاندونيسيه هي الاكبر ثم الجنسيه
اليمنيه هناك ايضا الجنسيات امريكيه
واوروبيه وعربيه واسيويه عدد ركاب
السعوديين على متن هذه السفينه ثلاثه عشر
سعوديا وكنا في لقطات مباشره قبل قليل من
داخل السفينه كما نشاهد هذه اللقطات عدنا
للتغطيه من داخل السفينه اذا
وسبعين راكبا يحاولون الان النزول الى بر
الامان بعد ما يقارب شمال ساعات يستغرقوها
في الرحله من بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك
فيصل الجويه البحريه عفوا في جده نتابع مع
زميل سلطان مسيوبي
السفينه هذه السفينه الضخمه كما ذكرتي
تقول
1687 شخص كما يظهر الان امامكم عائلات
اعداد من العائلات بشكل كبينتعرف عليك
طيب قد يكون يعيش البعض صدمه كما تشاهدون
حجم كبير من العائلات من مختلف جنسياتهم
يتواجدون على متن هذه السفينه بعد ان
وصلوا الى قاعده الملك عبد الله قاعه
الملك فيصل
سلطان يبدو بان الصوره تحكي كل شيء لا
ربما تحتاج الى احد لكي يقول لك بان
الوصول الى برلمان يمثل في مهم بالنسبه
لهم الابتسامه ربما تكفيه وتتحدث بكل
اللغات ودون ترجمه ودون حواجز ثقافيه او
لغويه اذا زميل سلطان السلم في هذه
اللقطات المباشره يواصل الجوله داخل سفينه
امانه من داخل قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
التي وصلت من ميناء بورت سودان وتقل على
متنها
راكبا وصلوا الى بر الامان نتابع مع سلطان
نعم كما تشاهدون هؤلاء العائلات والاطفال
نتعرف عليكم
طيب احنا حابين ناخذ الاقامه مع الطفل
الجميله هذا شو اسمه
انتم مقيمين في السودان ولا كنت مين في
السودان ايوه
كم مده اقامتكم في السودان بالضبط مده
اقامتنا تقريبا سبع سنوات او اكثر شوي كنا
مقيمين بمنطقه بحري كافوري شو المعاناه
والمشاهد اللي انتم عشتوها في السودان
اثناء الاشتباكات يعني هو الرعب الطياره
من فوقك كيف هيك
يعني رعب كان فظيع من كل تبغى تصير مذيعه
يا محمد معانا
هو الاجمل دائما السلطان للحقيقه للامانه
وهذا الاشتباكات وفي ظل هذه الحروب الامل
ربما دائما هو الاساس كما نتاهم نتابع
الابتسامه وصولها الاشخاص الى برلمان هو
الشيء الاهم في هذه التغطيه مباشره كما
نتابع بعد رحله طويله لابتسامه ما زالت
حاضره احساس بالامان الذي يشعر به هؤلاء
الركاب سلطان
بطبيعه الحال زميل محمد مشاعرهم اختلفت
فورا مشاهدتهم او دخولهم المياه الاقليميه
السعوديه وتحديدا عند وصولهم الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه هنا بجده بعد معاناه
كبيره بطبيعه الحال شاهدوها وعاشوها هنالك
في السودان بمختلف المناطق وسط الاشتباكات
المسلحه بين قوات الدعم وبين الجيش
السوداني اليوم لا لغه تطغى او مشهد يطغى
الا سوى الفرح على وجوه الاطفال بدايه
والعائلات وكبار السن وكذلك حتى الرجال ان
نشاهد اليوم الاغلب هم بعائلاتهم والاغلب
انه يحرص على مشاهده وصوله بلا بر الامان
بعد معاناه كبيره
عاشوها خلال الايام الماضيه داخل الاراضي
السودانيه ساعات ودقائق معدوده
وتبدا عمليات الانزال على قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده ومن ثم سوف يتم انهاء
كافه الاجراءات الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه
بمختلف جنسياتهم من قبل ممثليهم
والدبلوماسيين والسفراء المتواجدين كما
نؤكد هنالك وجود 46 امريكي و40 بريطانيا
على مثل هذه السفينه واكثر من 500 مواطن
اندونيسيا تواجدهما للحصه والعدد الاكبر
هم جميعهم كانوا يقيمون في السودان لاغراض
متعدده كممثلين دبلوماسيين او حتى كمقيمين
او بغرض التجاره او السكن ممكن ناخذ
لقاءات مع الشباب اللي موجودين نتعرف
عليكم معاويه شريف من سوريا
عدد كبير مشترين متواجدين على متن السفينه
فان كنتم في السودان وشبرت المشاهد اللي
شاهدتوها في اثناء الاشتباكات وعينيته
منها بشكل كبير يعني والله كنا بالسودان
بالعاصمه الخرطوم في الخرطوم نفسها
الخرطوم نفسه وكان فيه يعني نسمع اصوات
تقريبا كذا واخر الفتره لما قلنا انه خلص
بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي جدا يعني
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اسمي نور اسمي من وين ياسمين
اسمي اسمي نور نور من وين يا نور من سوريا
مقيمه في السودان مقيمه بالسودان مقيمه
بالسعوديه طيب كيف استطعت يعني كيفكم
بعمليه الاجلاء لما وصلتي بورس السودان
كيف استطعت الركوب على السفينه صراحه كان
كل شي منظم ما شاء الله وكان كذا في جنود
وكلهم قاعدين يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان
الموضوع جدا سهل وصلتوا مع السفاره
السعوديه هنا
تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم قالوا لهم نروح على
الميناء البري البحري وبس وجينا والحمد
لله كل شيء كان سهل الحمد لله على السلامه
ايضا ممكن ناخذكم في الجانب الاخر كما
تشاهدون اللقطات هي لقطات حصريه وخاصه
لقناه العربيه على متن هذه السفينه سفينه
امانه جد التي تقول 1687
شخص من 58 جنسيه فقط 13 سعودي متواجد على
متن هذه السفينه والاعداد المتبقيه هي
ومن ثم سوف يصلون مقرات سكنهم الى توفرتها
الحكومه السعوديه او بعد ذلك سوف يتم
التنسيق مع سفراتهم وممثليهم حتى يستطيعون
الذهاب الى بلدانهم في اقرب وقت ممكن بعد
انهاء كافه الاجراءات نؤكد ان هذه هي
السفينه سفينه الاجلاء السادسه التي عملت
عليها الحكومه السعوديه وتحديدا القوات
البحريه السعوديه خلال ثلاثه ايام الماضيه
نتحدث على 356 مواطن اجنبي وصلوا خلال
اليومين الماضيه واليوم نتحدث عن عدد كبير
1687 شخص فقط من ضمنهم سعودي
وصلوا الى قاعده الملك قيل قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده تحدثنا عن 1687 شخص اذا
يتحدث انه فقط 13 سعودي اين نتحدث عن 1674
مواطن اجنبي على متن هذه السفينه طاقه الى
356 السابقين نتحدث عن اكثر من 2030 مواطن
اجنبي تم اجلائهم من السودان من ميناء
بورسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
نواصل مع زميل سلطان السلمي وكاميرا
العربيه هذه اللقطات المباشره التي
نتابعها الان حصريا على شاشه العربيه من
داخل
سفينه امانه التي تقل على متنها 2006
راكبا تم اجلائهم من السودان بعد استمرار
المعارك لليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي هذه
السفينه هي الاكبر في عمليه اجلاء الرعايه
السعوديين العرب والاجانب من السودان
نتحدث عن
1687 راكبا هو رقم الاكبر الحصيله الاكبر
او الجنسيه الاكبر داخل هذه السفينه هي من
الجاليه الاندونيسيه بخمسمائه راكبا من
اندونيسيا هناك مثل ما اشرنا ثلاثه عشر
سعوديا سته واربعين امريكيا واربعون
بريطانيا تم اجلائهم بالاضافه الى جنسيات
اوروبيه عربيه
واسيويه من داخل السودان باشراف وتنسيق من
الحكومه السعوديه وحمايه البحريه السعوديه
الذين
يشاركون بشكل كبير في عمليات الاجلال
المستمره من بورتسودان بعد قرار اجلاء
الرعايه العرب والاجانب من هناك نظرا
لازدياد الاشتباكات وازداد وتيارات
الاشتباكات خلال الايام الماضيه اذا لقطات
مباشره من داخل السفينه السفينه امانه
الاولويه في هذه المرحله هي
للركاب ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه النساء
الاطفال بعد ذلك سيتم اجلال بقيه الركاب
الذين استغرقت بهم الرحله من بورسودان ما
يقارب ثمان ساعات بعد ذلك سيتم بالتنسيق
مع قنصلياتهم وسفاراتهم نقلهم الى بلدانهم
فيما بعد بالتنسيق ما بين السلطات
السعوديه وسلطات
او الممثليات الاجنبيه في المملكه من اجل
ايصال هؤلاء الاشخاص بسلامه الى بلدانهم
بعد ان وصلوا الى بره الامان كما نتابع في
هذه اللقطات المباشره
سلطان
اي نعم محمد اهلا بك مجددا بكافه مشاهدي
قناه العربيه
شاهد
فقط نشير الى صعوبه ايصال هذه الصور من
سفينه من الكاميرا العربيه ولكن هناك
لقطات سابقه تم تسجيلها
لعمليات الاجلاء المستقره من بورتسودان
وهذه العمليات التي انطلقت قبل ايام مع
استمرار المعارك ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع باشراف مباشر من
السلطات السعوديه وبالتنسيق مع
الدول الاجنبيه التي تسعى لاجلاء رعايها
من السودان وبالتاكيد تنسيق مع القوات
المسلحه السودانيه التي قامت بتامين وصوله
هؤلاء الاشخاص الى ميناء بورتودان ومنه
الى الموانع السعوديه وكما نتابع قبل قليل
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده
السعوديه عمليات الاجلاء مستمره كما هي
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم لليوم
الثاني عشر
على التوالي
اذا نحن في تغطيه مستمره على شاشه عربيه
لوصول اكبر
عدد من الرعايه الذين غادروا العاصمه
الخرطوم ومدن سودانيه اخرى بحثا على
الامان بعد استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان
اليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي نعود الى
هذه اللقطات المتقطع من داخل السفينه
السفينه امانه التي تقل على متنها
1608 او 88 راكبا مما يقارب 58 جنسيه هذه
العمليه هي الاكبر حتى الان
في السودان
في هذه اللقطات السفينه مؤهله بشكل كبير
لنقل
المئات من الركاب هذا النوع من السفن هو
ما يساهم في التشريع في عمليات نقل
الاشخاص الذين يبحثون عن بر الامان نتحدث
عن اجلاء
المئات من الاشخاص ومن جنسيات مختلفه
بالتنسيق مع سلطات السعوديه التي تقوم
بدور كبير فيما يتعلق
بمساعده هؤلاء الاشخاص للوصول الى بر
الامانه نتحدث عن 13 السعوديه الرقم
الاكبر كان من الجاليه الاندونيسيه
بخمسميه وستين راكبا اندونيسيا ايضا هناك
ركاب من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بسته
واربعين امريكيا 40 بريطانيين هناك ايضا
جنسيات اوروبيه مختلفه هناك ايضا رعايه
عرب
واجانب
لقطات تابعناها بشكل مختلف ومستمر قبل
قليل على شاشه العربيه من داخل السفينه
امانه التي حملت هذه الامانه الى بر
الامان
بورتودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذا الحرص على تامين سلامه وصوله هؤلاء
الاشخاص متابعنا في لقطات سابقه حضور
الممثليات
والقنصليات والدبلوماسيين الاجانب
لاستقبال رعايا بلدانهم لدى وصولهم الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده اذا
الاستقبال بالحلوى والورود واهم امر يتعلق
بهذا الاستقبال هو توفير بيئه امنه لهؤلاء
الاشخاص بعد ايامنا الاشتباكات المستمره
في العاصمه الخرطومة
الصوره تتحدث
محمد نشاهد الان هذه اللقطات امامكم
مباشره عند باب هذه السفينه الضخمه التي
اقلت هؤلاء الرعايه يتم استقبالهم من قبل
ممثلي وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدد كبير
من القطاع او القيادات الامنيه السعوديه
التابع للقوات البحريه وزاره الدفاع
لاستقبال هؤلاء السيدات وهؤلاء العائلات
والرجال بعد وصولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بعد رحله استمرت لقرابه من ثمانيه
الى عشره ساعات مشاهده العمليات الاستقبال
بعد ان قمنا بكم بجوله خاصه داخل هذه
السفينه سفينه أمان لانه قلت لكم خارجا
لعمليات الانزال كما يظهر الان امامكم يتم
انزال العائلات والسيدات بدايه نشاهد
الابتسامه وهي بمقدمه وجيه هؤلاء الرائع
نتعرف عليك
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على شكرا طيب ممكن اسالك ايش
المشاهد اللي شفتيها في السودان كل شيء اي
شيء ضرب رصاص دبابات اي شيء الحمد لله لما
وصلت القاعده ايش اللي شعرت فيه خوف خوفنا
طبعا بس الحمد لله يعني تسهلت لما وصلتوا
السعوديه هنا الحمد لله طبعا كان طمانينه
يعني جينا من وضع سيء جدا بس الحمد لله
اللي كنت مقيمه في السودان ولا تعملي في
السودان كنت شغاله في السودان فالحمد لله
ايش الدعوات السفينه اي دعوه في الحياه
طبعا
شكرا معلش بس شكرا شكرا كما ذكرنا ايضا
القطاعات الامنيه تقوم بمساعده العائلات
من خلال مساعدتهم في حمل حقائبهم لكبار
السن والسيدات تحديدا ايضا نشاهد عمليات
الاجلاء او النزول من هذه السفينه ضخمه
التي بدات العمليات من خلال ربع ساعه
الماضيه ومتوقع خلال الساعه او النصف
القادمه ان تنتهي عملي
تنتهي عمليات النزول من ثم بعد ذلك انهاء
اجراءات سفرهم ومن ثم ركوب الحافلات التي
تم تخصيصها من قبل الحكومه السعوديه الى
اربعه فنادق تم تم تخصيصها من قبل جهه
المختصه لتسكين هؤلاء الرعايه بمختلف
جنسيتهم ودولهم واعمارهم وتوفير كافه
الاحتياجات الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه نتحدث
عن كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه يتم
تسكينهم في غرف مخصصه
لحالتهم الصحيه ومتابعه على مدار الساعه
من قبل ممثلين وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
والقطاعات العامه الرقم الاهم سلطان هو
الفستميه راكب عدد كبير جدا هل نتوقع
المزيد من سفن المماثله ما تبقى من رعايه
الذين يحاولون الهرب من ما يجري من
اشتباكات في السودان
بالفعل المتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه انتم
تكون هنالك عمليات اجلاء مستمره خلال
الساعات القادمه او يوم غدا كما ذكر
السفير السعودي في الخرطوم ليتم استقبال
كافه الطلبات ودراستها والموافقه بما
يتناسب حتى يتم اجلائهم عبر سفن بحريه
ونشاهد
اهلا وسهلا حياك الله ويلكم
كما نشاهد الجميع يعبرون عن مشاعرهم
وسعادتهم الكبيره التي غمرتهم بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده كما نشاهد الاطفال وعائلاتهم
وكبار السن وعدد كما ذكرنا سوف يتم انزال
بدايه كبار السنود الخاصه والنساء ومن ثم
تباعا بقيه
دائما بالاضافه الى الورود والحلوى يا هلا
وسهلا حياكم الله هذه المفردات التي تدل
على حسن الضيافه والترحيب بهؤلاء الاشخاص
الذين يبحثون عن بر الامان بعد اشتباكات
مستمره لليوم الثاني عشر على قبل قليل
اتوقع كنا نستمع لتصريحات من احد الرعايه
البريطانيين الذين
وصلوا الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وكان
يتحدث عن
تقديري لهذه الجهود
لايصاله هؤلاء الرعايه الى برلمان
وتمنياتي للشعب السوداني بسلام والاستقرار
اذا كما نتابع على شاشه العربيه الان
عمليات نزول الركاب من السفينه امانه التي
وصلته على متنها
1876 وسبعه وثمانون راكبا رقم الدقيق 1687
راكب من 58 جنسيه 46 امريكي و40 بريطاني
بالاضافه الى 13 سعوديين ولكن الجنسيه
الاكبر من اندونيسيا ب5 60 راكبا
اندونيسيا اللقطات مباشره مع الزميل سلطان
السنم
محمد الجميع هنا يعبر عن امتنانه وتقديره
من قبل كافه الرعايه الذين التقينا بهم
على الهواء مباشره وحتى قبل عمليات البث
او المباشر كانوا جميعهم يعملون او
يتحدثون عن تقدير من الحكومه السعوديه وعن
كيفيه استقبالهم وتعاملهم وتعاملهم
والتنسيق العالي من قبل القوات البحريه
السعوديه ووزاره الخارجيه السعوديه مع
حكوماتهم للتسهيل عليهم واجلائهم من بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده كما نشاهد الان امامكم لا تزال
عمليات الانزال مستمره وكما اشرت الحكومه
السعوديه ووزاره الخارجيه في وقت سابق
انها سوف تتعامل مع كافه الرعايه الاجانب
كما تتعامل مع مواطنيها من خلال تقديم
كافه الخدمات والتسهيلات وتلبيه كافه
احتياجات الرعايه اثناء عمليات اجلائهم
بره من الخ سودان وصولا بحرا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه وكذلك بعد وصولهم الى
جده من خلال عمليه تسكينه وتلبيه كافه
احتياجاتهم وتسهيل اجراءات السفر كل هذه
الاجراءات والتسهيلات والتلسيقات الكبيره
التي عملت عليها الحكومه السعوديه هي
لتلبيه احتياجاتها هؤلاء الرعايه الذين
عاشوا بطبيعه الحال معاناه كبيره واليوم
الحكومه السعوديه لتقديم كافه الخدمات
الانسانيه اثناء عمليه التنقل واثناء
عمليه التنسيق وصولا الى مقرات سكنهم بجده
ومن ثم بعد ذلك الى بلدانهم ايضا فيما
نشاهد الان بعض القيادات الخاصه بالقوات
البحريه السعوديه تعمل على توجيه
الزملاء والقطاع والافراد والضباط من خلال
تسهيل عمليات النزول واستقبالهم بالحلوى
والورود وبعض الهدايا والترحيب بهم
بترحيبات السعوديه بطبي
عمليه الانزال وعمليه انهاء الاجراءات
معكم الهواء مباشره ومن ثم نقلهم الى
مقرات سكنهم عبر تخصيص اربعه فنادق في جده
نتحدث عن اكثر من 2030 مواطن اجنبي وصلوا
عبر عمليات الجلاله التي عملت عليها
القوات البحريه السعوديه والحكومه
السعوديه خلال اليومين الماضيه عبر سته
سفن
خمسه منها بحريه والسادس هذه السفينه
التجاريه التي تسمى
بامانه جده ايضا متوقع استمرار العمليات
بشكل كبير شكرا سلطان وسنبقى مع هذه
اللقطات المباشره لعمليه نزول ركابه من
داخل السفينه امانه وامانه جده التي وصلت
قبل قليل الى ميناء قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في مدينه جده سعوديه وعلمتها
1687 راكبا من جنسيات مختلفه نتحدث عن 13
سعوديه 46 امريكيا و40 بريطانيا ولكن
الجنسيه والرقم الاكبر كان من اندونيسيا ب
راكب بين الجنسيه
كما نتحدث هناك جنسيات اوروبيه عربيه
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن دول
اخرى في استمرار لعمليات الاجلاء من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بقيه المدن
السودانيه الاخرى عبر ميناء بورتو السودان
كما نتابع في هذه العمليات المستمره بعد
سماحه الاشتباكات ربما او هدوء الاشتباكات
بوتيره ما تسمح بنقل هؤلاء الذين يرغبون
بمغادره السودان بامان وعودتهم الى
بلدانهم عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
عمليات جلاء مستمره منذ ايام اذا جنسيات
مختلفه تحدثنا عن جنسيات اوروبيه من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
السعوديه من اندونيسيا من اليمن حتى من
جنسيات سودانيه ايضا في محاولات مستمره
لنقل هؤلاء الى برلمان بعد استمرار
الاشتباكات وسنوافيكم ايضا بالمزيد من
التفاصيل التي سنتابعها على شاشه العربيه
لاستم رار عمليات الاجلاء بالتنسيق مع
السلطات السودانيه وباشراف مباشر
وحمايه من قبل البحريه السعوديه وسلطات
السعوديه بشكل كامل بكافه القطاعات
المرتبطه بشكل مباشر مع هذه لقطات التي
نتابعها على شاشه العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات